another Republican debate happened and I
didn't watch why would anyone watch the
NIT Tournament that's what it is the
national Invitational Tournament for all
the teams that didn't make March Madness
and Nikki Haley supposedly has pulled
ahead against DeSantis in New Hampshire
and all the headlines go who cares I
mean talk about a empty Victory what's
the point of what they're doing doesn't
he hold like a 20o lead over everyone so
I don't even know why they continue to
do these debates tensions between Nikki
Haley Donald Trump boil over at
Republican debate it doesn't matter he's
winning the nomination it's it's it he's
not there it's not the real deal but
anyway if you were wondering Nikki Haley
uh has pulled into second place in one
state over Ronda santz like the Dutch do
in track and field we're just going for
the bronze at this point when you line
up at the line and dig your running
cleats into those heels and you look to
your left and you see a Jamaican dude
and you look to your right and you see
an African-American you're playing for
bronze and that's exactly what's going
on with this Republican field